how are you doing
i am great how are you yeah really great
you look
great but how you feeling you feeling
great too you look great too
i'm feeling good it must be crazy being
an interviewer right now
are you like only doing zoom stuff yeah
yeah it's kind of a bummer you know i
really wish that you know especially
with somebody like you where i'm just
like a giant
fan that you know
you are grace i'm going to tell you
something right now every now and then
every now and then i have one of these
awkward moments where i'm interviewing
somebody
and i'm looking at the face of somebody
who made me cry
and it's weird because you made me
cry and it's always a little bit awkward
when i finally
am face to face with somebody who's
brought me to tears before
oh well i'm sorry but thank you that's
so sweet you're so sweet is that a real
background behind you
i have to know it is yeah that's my
house yeah
wow a little studio moment i see you
yeah okay i need one of those i need
like a nice little studio thingy here
you do so are you are you are you doing
school what are you doing right now
yeah i'm doing school i just had school
this morning
um yeah yeah
how was that it's uh
so fun i love it it's the best part of
my day
uh with uh with repeat i i love the
i i love the track what what did you
want to say
this time around you know what
i just wanted to have fun i
used to struggle so much making happy
songs it was my
biggest biggest struggle it is so hard
because it's
so easy to be sad and it's so easy to
make
really good balance and i had never made
i feel like a really fun
song and i was having all these fun
experiences you know
like growing up and going out and i'm i
have all
this inspiration and i my life is
actually
fairly happy and i have never written
like a
really happy extravagant thrilling song
so that that was the inspiration behind
the song just like
no nothing too nothing too deep
do you do you find that i because i've
talked to so many artists
where you know oftentimes the low times
lead to fantastic art
and when you realize the the greatness
that can come out of a low time do you
find
or did you find in the past that you
would sometimes maybe manipulate a
situation
or seek out opportunities to be a little
low just to reap the rewards
of what could come out of it
um girl you are like reading me right
now
very strange uh yes definitely
definitely definitely
um yeah definitely i think even
subconsciously as an
artist i think that like artists artists
tend to uh you know because we're always
telling our story
and painting a book for people with us
being the main character
always so i think we tend to
victimize ourselves a little more than
the average person
in low situations and stuff like that
and the the style of the video uh it's
incredible
everything about it just looks awesome
how much does the the
the when the song is done are you
already thinking about visuals
while the song is still sort of being
produced or
do the visuals come after the fact does
one inspire the other
um sometimes i used to
always see a music video the second i
finished a song i would like
feel it i would see it i would pretend
that i was in the video
but lately that just hasn't been
happening this this video
didn't happen like that this video was
actually so last minute
we like threw it together right before
i'm in la right now right before
i came out um into la because everyone
loved the song so much
and i was iffy about the song it is now
like my favorite song i've ever released
but i was like
i don't know like i don't know if it's
the best song and then everyone was like
you know
pushing me forward and so yeah so then
we came up with the treatment plan and
like
whipped up a video really quick and uh
but it actually turned out amazing and
yeah now i love it is there what's that
what's the sort of end game
after after this is there a full length
sort of down the road or are you more
eps singles what's your what's your vibe
right now
i literally have no idea i
feel like i'm at the point in my life
i just i feel like
done with the planning and with all of
that i feel like if it happens it
happens if things come together they do
like who would have thought that i had
like a whole treatment plan
before this whole little little rabble
moment of mine
and um you know because i released
letters vol 1
and that's just there now so i don't
know if i should like
do a volume two to that or not
just do letters volume three
that that's a really good idea that's a
good idea that down
i have such incredible memories and i
remember exactly where i was and what i
was doing the first time i saw the clip
of you
on agt what are your memories
from that time um
very limited i remember like specific
blips of like eating like a hamburger
in l.a that's a scene in my mind i
remember
from that time and um
yeah and i remember nick cannon talking
about
uh how he needed to do his homework and
how he needed to film quick
i remember that so
so here's my thing you you you're not
the first person to sort of be thrust
into the spotlight at a young age
um and what comes with that is you
suddenly are responsible for all the
emotional side of being stable and
talented
that is almost unnatural for somebody at
that age to
have do you remember was there a moment
where you said
i don't know what the hell this is or
even
how to process this because none of that
is natural
for a 12 year old yeah it was a very
very unnatural little moment and
absolutely all the time oh my god
literally all the time
it was actually i mean it's so
weird that period of my life because
it's just
every single memory are complete
opposites like it was
either the absolute worst time in my
life
or like the best time in my life you
know what i'm saying like no
in between every single memory is one or
the other
um but i mean honestly it made it made
me a better person it made my family
a better person like i can't imagine who
we would be or where we would be
or anything like that if it weren't for
i feel like honestly that was like a
divine intervention all of that just
personally and how much it affected our
lives and
made us look at ourselves and change
things and learn how to stabilize
everything you know
and it does it does it makes you look at
it it messes with your self-confidence
it messes with your self-worth
it messes with your mental health when
did you realize
what was real and what wasn't
i uh i've never been super
in touch with how i feel and that's why
i love music and i love writing songs
because it's just a weird way that like
extracts all that goop from my soul
you know what i'm saying because it can
like build up a lot
so i i feel like i just tend to have
reactions to things and not know what
they're connected to
so i'll feel bad about myself or
or lose my self-image and be like why
literally why is this happening
even though obviously it was happening
for the reason we all know
um but i to answer your questions sorry
um i haven't done an interview in a
while
uh when did i decide what was real you
said i
i think that i decided what was real
every time i was with my sister
honestly yeah and i know i i talked
about her on the show
and but that that was that's the realest
part of me
you know what i'm saying and i don't i
don't think that i would be
okay without her through all that at all
um you read what i read why do you think
people are so shocked that a young woman
that a young woman changed so much
both physically and aesthetically
between the ages of 12 and 17.
the shock seems absurd to me yeah
well you know what it's fine
is that not just what happens um
well they they don't think so apparently
they don't think so
uh you know what the time zone
on the internet is like a different
planet years or like minutes
so i think you know there are my
fans and supporters who have been with
me through everything and they're like
where have you guys been but i i just
feel like people
have always loved to talk about me and
even when i was 12
they like always were like me making
jokes about me and talking about me and
i just
attract that i don't know what's wrong
with me i'm just i guess it's just in my
aura or something
uh star girl is incredible it's getting
a sequel uma thurman is joining the cast
what are your thoughts on that
i'm really excited i'm actually here for
filming i'm starting pre-production
next like week or something so yeah it's
pretty crazy
i'm excited have you met uma yet
no i i think i'm meeting her really soon
though with kovid they're like putting
off all in-person things till the last
minute but
i i did a zoom thing with her and she's
so sweet she's literally so down to
earth she had like her dogs barking
oh my god yeah very sweet woman
and uh where does so so what is i i mean
believe me i i don't want to sort of put
pressure on you and get you to map out
the next few years of your life
but let's just say acting um is there a
direction
that's different from star girl that you
would like to
that you would like to go and is there a
world that exists right now that you
think you could fit into
absolutely yes yes i
uh i i i don't
i don't want to put too much pressure on
acting that's such an
untouched part of my life like i don't
want to strip the fun
from that you know i want it to stay
special and i want it to stay new
so i don't want to lean too much into it
but i
i would love to do like more abstract
roles and things like that because i'm
i'm actually very interested in movies
and cinema and and
um all that stuff and like camerawork
and blah blah blah
so yeah are you are you are you also
interested
in every now and then just getting to
not be you
yes oh i love it i love it
i do that just in my day time just you
know little characters
and things like that it's nice do
you have the ukulele anywhere in your
general vicinity right now or is that
a part of your life that doesn't exist
anymore
okay well those are two very big options
um that moment is not dead
but unfortunately i don't which was a
mistake
i regret it very deeply because i've
needed it a few times
but i had a lot of luggage that i need
to bring here i'm here for like a month
listen i am i'm such a huge fan as i as
i said already congratulations
on everything and the song is great and
hopefully
the next time we do this we can both be
in the same room yes oh my gosh
love you thank you all right
congratulations take it easy
i really appreciate your time thank you